[Applause]
i just want to make a statement right
now
make it because i know everybody's
wanting me to talk about this i'm going
to make it maybe
famously this is important i'm not
watching cuties
you know what i'm glad you still
watching i've been waiting to hear your
response
to the cuties controversy this whole
time listen everybody just told me bro
you gotta respond about cuties
i'm not watching cuties wow i can't
watch it because here's the thing
there's no positive scenario that comes
out of me watching it
do you know the movie we're all talking
about yeah netflix is about like
these little girls in france whatever
they join like a twerking crew or some
[ __ ] like that yeah
my assumption is
well people are saying that it's
pedophilia
yeah that's what they're saying yeah but
you know how like
everybody likes to call everything
pedophilia that's the new [ __ ] yeah
right that's like that's off-white yeah
it's like you everybody got to call out
pedophilia
it's almost getting so excessive that my
attitude is like
is that really pedophilia it's almost
that excessive right
so everybody's going you gotta cancel
netflix over this this is horrible
pedophilia is that the
my assumption with this is the marketing
of the movie
is probably way more egregious than the
movie but here's why i'm not going to
see the movie
i want to see little girls sexualized
regardless my assumption is
that the movie is exposing the
sexualization
of kids yes and how it's bad and
unfortunately
you need to sexualize or objectify kids
to showcase that
it's the same thing like if you want to
show birth you got to show a baby coming
out of a [ __ ] it's by proxy you got to
show some [ __ ]
that being said i don't want to see it
if if schindler's list didn't show the
atrocities that happened
it's not schindler's list that's an
interesting point so this movie my girl
started watching like 10 minutes
couldn't be like trust us
yo yes this [ __ ] is
you saw some smoke coming out you don't
know what that was it didn't seem that
bad
yeah yeah it's a bonfire yeah all movies
were black and white everything looked
depressing
basically the point is you watched this
girl we quit 10 minutes in i was like
turn this [ __ ] off oh you tried it yeah
can't together as like no like she
wanted to watch it i was like all right
let's see what everybody's talking about
before any like actual sex
sexualization [ __ ] happens you just see
her like looking at the magazines
whatever of like
this is what pretty girls look like i
guess but that's the commentary is
girls i think as young girls minds get
so warped by
society that a lot of times they try to
sexualize themselves younger that's
true and that's a valid point son what
they got
girls wearing makeup at these little uh
what are they called like where you see
which oh beautiful
beauty pageant oh yeah toddlers and
tiaras like why are they wearing
makeup yeah it's horrendous the whole
point of blush
do you know what the point of blush is
what and even lipstick
it's when a girl is in a sexual state
when she's actually like hot
and like heavy and she's horny she's
ready to [ __ ] her cheeks redden
and her lips redden so makeup is
supposed to
reenact what is happening to a human
being a woman
when they're getting [ __ ] yeah why are
you painting girls to do that
what's that yes it does happen to black
people yes it does
where do you think red bone comes from
what do you think red bone comes from
yes that's a girl getting boned yeah
yeah
we tried we tried to save up we just got
to save it
we tried to save it right we tried i
tried to jump right on top of it
all right so tell me how quick did you
come into the movie you said you only
watched i know right
uh the thumbnail
[Laughter]
before she could even scroll down she's
like do you want to watch yes
yes yes
let's watch a social dilemma point is
point is i think we all agree yeah
society's [ __ ] up you could execute
that in a way better way maybe or you
don't even need to showcase it but then
i started thinking right
i'm like watching this show on another
show on netflix it's absolutely
hilarious you actually watch it called
cobra kai
i started watching that [ __ ] is
fantastic fantastic so much fun what is
that very good
it is a modern day uh
sequel if you will to the karate kid
but now the protagonist is
the other guy that the karate kid beat
so you're watching kids either way
well here's the thing they're adults now
okay right but i'm watching it
and then there is kids in high school
that are like
making out and the girls that are in
high school are all like done up and
sexualized and maybe the
actors are older than 18 but they're
supposed to be portraying kids in high
school and then i started to think wait
a minute
what about gossip girl those girls were
supposedly and guys were supposed to be
in high school
what about when we were young they was
okay when we were young but what's the
show
uh not saved by the bell the next one
they're older beverly hills beverly
hills now two and all this kind of [ __ ]
i'm like wait a minute
how many high school shows where they
show kids dry humping and [ __ ] and
all this kind of stuff are just
regular and normal and i'm like wait a
minute
this is adults watching kids be
sexual yeah there was that show skins i
think
it was like a british show super well
it's like women you have you are
entertaining adults with kids
babies what's the [ __ ] hbo show with
zendaya or whatever
yeah oh euphoria euphoria we called that
that exact [ __ ] and i was like yo
why are you why are you making it okay
like
it's just weird to me to and the cuties
is the first time there's any pushback i
think it's super egregious
yeah it's further these are like 10 year
olds 10 year olds close to 16 17.
exactly but it is weird that there's
never been any pushback about that at
all
i also think it's because it's girls
keep going that like
if you see young girls being sexualized
like 10 11 i think we feel weirder about
it
opposed to like if you see like young
guys we're into yeah
yeah mark catholic tell us what what is
you
yeah yeah they didn't care about me
nobody seems a kid i was a cutie back
then yeah
but like yeah so like in
in the same way that like we're more
offended by an older man
like approaching or trying to like
molest a young girl then
then a female teacher molesting one a
young boy yeah
like i think we have a different sexual
attitude towards men 100
but those shows are people are kids of
the same age hooking up
right but there's boys involved so like
oh it's like ah because the boy is the
same age as the girl then
yeah but if it's only girls that are
younger i feel like people that's when
people get weird about it they do get
weird about we have a protective
instinct which we should over women
yeah obviously but it is interesting
that like
watching teenagers be sexual is kind of
like
normal this is weird you awarding to use
but i actually think the difference is
like
puberty if you're in high school that's
happened if you're in cuties it hasn't
that's true this is like an
actual physical child you can get a 20
year old everybody's over 18 like you
said and gossip girl
all these shows there is no way a 20
year old can be in cutie's
acting like that's a great point we
understand
that people are sexual
after puberty yes right and that is kind
of normal because we went through that
and we were that way
right and yeah evolutionarily that's you
are ready to reproduce now right right
right yeah yeah but even though
we don't think that an older person
should do that but we understand so it
is a
it is relatable we're like i remember
being 16 this is what i went through
right nobody's watching like yeah 16
year olds are like oh i remember that as
yes
right yeah but those kids are pre
sex pre being horny pre
anything they should not be even
introduced to a sexual realm
and they're being exploited in that way
yeah and even if the point is yo this is
really bad
it still does feel weird to watch it
because i know it's bad
i don't need you to tell me it's bad
right like is anybody going oh wow
exploiting children is bad like i think
the message
could be for women that it's not like
this idea that
where you're you get sexualized or
whatever so early
there's like something [ __ ] up about
that whereas i think guys know that i
think a lot of women just kind of grow
up with it and they don't
like they don't think about it right
honestly um
i would watch the show but [ __ ] it i
wouldn't watch the show but
i don't think there's that much wrong
with it because it's
an art depiction of what's actually
happening in reality so
because this is actually happening there
are kids this age doing the exact same
things online
it's actually a window for parents to
see like hey this is what your child is
a commentary
so i have to have something to comment
on yes
that is a good point and i understand
that and i think that that's why people
defend it and i'm sure that's what
netflix was thinking they're like yo
this is
i'm sure that a lot of people were
putting this out like this is an
important piece and we need to expose
what these young girls are actually put
through and went through yeah
but i'm looking at some of like the
angles of the shots
yeah that's the thing somebody had to
choose
oh yeah to zoom in on little girls
bodies
not like i watched the guy like a
youtuber do like a compilation like
reaction to it yeah so he shows all the
like the wild clips
yes and it's like three minutes of these
little kids twerking
and it's like it's not only like here's
a wide shot
of girls dancing and there's some
twerking going on it's that girl is
working
close up of her butt yeah young
girl i think one of the girls has her
top off and once
they didn't show on youtube but
apparently that's what i read i'm not
sure that's that's true yeah i don't
know also the french are mad
french are mad weird when it comes to
that's another thing oh their age of
consent is like 15. they keep trying to
drop that [ __ ] there's like famous
french like philosophers that have said
that what's the guy who's
the point of me i don't know
come on there's a but there's some guy
who was saying like the best pleasure
ever
as a teenager what is the guy yeah i'm
not familiar son you are french and
catholic you definitely got [ __ ] up
100 point is it's a
it seems to be unnecessary it seems to
be egregious yeah
it's overdone you can get the point
across probably with lists
but in their minds we're making a
commentary again you gotta give them
something to comment on
yeah but i just think i don't think they
thought through how it would actually be
received like viscerally
it's like i uh i don't want i'm trying
to equate it to something like
like a rape scene in a movie yeah i
think that's decent like you like you
need to show
this like egregious thing that happened
in the movie but you don't need to show
all of it i remember there's a game of
thrones things the scene and then the
shower
those are the two things right that like
sets it like there's the rape scene
and then it's the shower what you show
the shame after yeah the girl
i got you guys i got you it sounded to
send
crazy
off
yeah you need the scene and then you
need the shower yeah but we don't think
you're not attacking the shower after
watching you're not
you're not mentioning the [ __ ] why am i
showering after watching in the morning
that's what we're wondering bro yeah
we're looking
[Laughter]
yeah i don't i think clear that chain
back oh wow i got a crazy topic keep
going go go go go go go
after this after this okay no i think we
just misunderstood what you were saying
yeah you need the shower to show the
shame
that she's experiencing yeah exactly
context you just need the context around
the
yeah assault there was actually a scene
in game of thrones where jaime
raped cersei or something like all game
of thrones was was racist
well this one was like particularly like
non-consensual
and there was a lot of pushback but
their point was like we're trying to
show the horror of it
you can't just avoid it like it doesn't
happen people need to see how awful this
is
and i guess the idea is maybe then
anybody who could get
turned that way or whatever would be
like oh that's [ __ ] terrible thing to
do
yeah but that's the thing is like i
don't think many people are going
through life like
um yeah it's okay to rape and then you
see game of thrones you're like oh man
i'm not raping that's crazy like thank
god you showed me how bad it was and now
i know i really shouldn't do it right
i feel like they're picking things we
already know are wrong
and we have no interest in doing and
then
acting as if they should get this like
pat on the back for pointing it out
hey murder's bad yeah
dude i mean like and that's almost my my
my annoyance with this whole like
everything's a pedophile movement it's
like
do you think you're saying something
that we don't know right like yeah
everybody's against pedophilia yeah 100
yeah everybody
i think maybe the commentary of this is
like a large
part of like the anti-slut-shaming
movement is it's okay for a girl to be
sexual
i think maybe the comment is cool have
that but there's also
there's an age of which it's appropriate
and there's an age when can a girl
when can a girl be sexual 18. what age
18. yeah that was the right answer yeah
yeah yeah yeah i wasn't sure what you're
going to say but you said the right
that's a weird thing man as a parent
as a parent you are going to get to
decide when your daughter
is going to sexualize you try but girls
i mean like what are you really going to
be able to stop don't let her buy the
clothes
there you go so then they sneak it they
buy it they put it in their bag and then
they change it when they get to school
and [ __ ] like that like
that's the thing that's why i feel this
show is good to show
people i think part of the outrage is
because
people were like wait what the [ __ ] this
is happening i think part of that is
that outreach
because one people don't know what's
happening and then two it's like ill
you're putting this
thing in my face that i'm not i don't
feel comfortable watching you don't
think people know that these kids are
being sexualized
i don't think all right dude it's
[ __ ] i don't think all people are i
wasn't aware of how young
the people that don't know they actually
tell you some [ __ ] they're like really
[ __ ] it was like it broke my heart
dude i was in japan
okay we're in this uh i forget the name
of the street but it's a very famous
street it's like uh where all the uh
hari
zuki girls hang out um super pac
street i mean like guaranty corona if
this was corona time forget you can't
even move
ramped okay we go downstairs to this
like photo booth
arcade imagine an arcade but there's no
arcades it's just
different photo booths where you can
morph your face and your features
and it's just teenage japanese girls in
there
morphing their facial features to kind
of look like anime and like making their
lips bigger and their eyes bigger and
making their faces change
and you're in there you're like oh this
is just girls doing like fun like little
girl [ __ ]
and then i sat there for a second i'm
with my girl i'm like oh this is
horrifying
they're 14 years old already picking out
everything that's wrong with their face
and changing it to have this idealistic
looking face that they'll never be able
to achieve
it's not going to be a [ __ ] cartoon
they're not even picking it out that
the machine the machine is giving you
got to make this bigger you got to
change this
i mean how [ __ ] up is that like you
throw a filter on your face and then the
filter basically goes yo that's what's
[ __ ] up on you
yeah you would look better like this
it's crazy
makes your nose thinner not why would i
know
like it does all these little things man
so i do agree with you there is that
conversation to be had i think you can
do that without close-ups of a [ __ ]
eleven-year-old guy
yeah i should you should watch it before
you say like
yeah maybe i i'm not going to but yeah
yes and that's the other two
things they trick you into watching them
[ __ ] you don't even want to watch like i
don't
even if i watch it and i go i understand
the point they're trying to make and
that's kind of like what i'm coming out
with right now
i don't want to have that in my head
yeah absolutely not
i didn't know it was as early as it was
13 14 even i'd be like i guess i could
see it
i did not know if she's like [ __ ] six
in the movie i think i don't know
i know and i think she's like 11. she
looks mad i don't know i don't know
young girls ages i don't care but uh i
was like oh it's that early
yeah oh it's like elementary school [ __ ]
that's crazy yeah like we all watched
the epstein documentary
i don't think it would be better with
like a reenactment of him
yeah like we got the point yeah you just
told us what happened and then we're
good
yeah i didn't leave it being like well
the plane like what was it on the plane
show us the massage
yeah how did it work what do you mean
his dick was egg-shaped
show us the dick yeah that's so true
like you know how they do those
reenactments and those like murder shows
where like the girls kill their husbands
like this is how it happened it's like
we don't need that yeah
yeah it's a weird thing to defend like
when people are defending it
as like oh some art pieces like eh
there's a limitation with art
yeah not everything got to be art